I feel horrible yeah well that's good
that's what I'm here for no I really
what I said I just ate like I just I
just realized that's all I've had today
I just ate a bunch of croissants
what
what are you talking about you did you
feel weak in the legs you
what are you talking about I'm quick
did you hit a Frenchman with your car
yeah
it's true I mean there's there's no
point to this story just like realizing
I I just have like four I just had a
bunch of croissants
and now I just feel terrible
if you want you can always throw up into
the ocean
that happened yes I think we're thrown
up on the show before uh and I don't
think it's happened yet but there's
always the first time so keep watching
I'm gonna shake I feel good now that
I've addressed it I feel kind of good
you know I will tell you something you
look very good you're clean shaven in
the movie though you have crazy beard
and uh you I didn't realize you could
grow a beard like this I think we have a
picture look
that is a Unabomber beard
I took that picture in a porta potty
that's makes it even just grosser oh
yeah you could tell yeah yeah that's a
porta potty all right that was and with
my hair pulled back my hair was pulled
back in a ponytail I thought I I looked
a little like Paul Mitchell uh
describe any tank tops that's nice
you were in there and you were just
having croissants yeah
I always feel like a porta potty is the
best place to have a croissant sure
yeah so so what I'm curious so and then
you shaved the beard but you did it in
stages I think we have a photo of one of
these you went to this stage after we
wrapped you know you could only go why
did you do that I like it that also look
at my chest I probably should have kept
going
what is that but yeah then you just
that's the you know it's what when you
shave a beard you kind of have to go
piecemeal yeah I think yeah and then so
you go with the sideburns and then it
ends with the mustache and then finally
to the you know you end with the with
the Hitler no you don't you you didn't
end with the little Hitler stash did you
do that's the last thing you it's like a
lot because you can't really go anywhere
after that right so you just
you know it's like wiping the last crumb
away from a cookie and so I ended with
that I hope you didn't stick with that
stash for very long you can't you can't
you can't isn't it weird that like he
ruined a look
I mean he was such a bad guy such a bad
guy and he actually because beforehand
he had chaplain it people people a lot
of people wore that mustache that's a
fashionable thing and he was such a bad
guy hipsters don't even do it no
no one can do it not
not only that he ruined the name yeah
you don't hear the name anymore
you know first or last name no no it's
called Hitler's
you gotta try to sandwich it Hitler's
yeah come on into Hitler's with half
price